there's been an awakening
have you felt it
the dark side and the light
you
hey youtubers is charlie no surprise
here they're doing Lego episode 7 with a
really cool thing is that there's going
to be content that will bridge the gap
between return of the jedi and episode 7
if you saw the lego movie or you've
played any of the other lego games like
they even did a DC lego game Stephen
Amell did his voice for Green Arrow
stranded on an island with only one goal
survive
to survive I must become someone else
something green and pointy and arrow II
you can kind of think of this is a
playable comedy version of Star Wars
Episode seven now obviously there's
going to be a lot of Triple A games
based on the new movies so if you're a
bigger fan of the traditional game
presentation the traditional types of
narratives then they'll have those too
this seems more like the tongue-in-cheek
star wars game you play in the middle of
finals or if you have like a ton of work
something that isn't going to wind up
being the most difficult game you've
ever played in your entire life just
nothing fun to blow a couple hours on so
if you're strapped for cash I wouldn't
worry about buying it and yeah I'm gonna
buy it I'll totally play it but I'm
probably mostly going to be using it for
comedy gifs that's kind of where I'm at
with a lot of episode 7 stuff right now
where I've seen it a couple times
thought all the thoughts look for all
the Easter eggs and now is the time for
turning it into really weird art and
using it for comedy with other mashups
if you're not on Facebook that's
actually where i post most of that stuff
those little small videos are actually
my most fun thing to do when I'm not
making big videos for the youtube
channel important stuff though of course
they got all the actors to do their
voices for their characters it's
probably part of their contracts like if
you do this we'll pay you extra money
but it'll be a seamless experience for
the audience it won't be some weird
person voicing your character it's
dropping on all consoles PC everywhere
on jun 28th will call that shut up and
take my money day but in related news i
know a lot of you wondering about Star
Wars rogue one are they going to drop a
teaser soon is there going to be a super
bowl teaser I'm not expecting it I don't
think Lucasfilm really needs to spend
the money for super bowl ad that doesn't
mean that they won't do anything for
super bowl sunday there might be some
fun Star Wars content but what I'm
really expecting is is it they'll attach
a rogue one trailer of some sort to
Captain America Civil War you have to
remember that Disney owns all these
companies now so a lot of the new things
that they drop for Star Wars Marvel
things are all grouped together big
Marvel movie comes the thought is that
you know most of those people probably
also like Star Wars so we'll put some
star wars with this too but that doesn't
mean that we're not going to get any
rogue one stuff it just means that I'm
not expecting any this weekend if there
is I will totally do a video for if
there is any Star Wars related stuff I'm
mostly just expecting Marvel and Fox
stuff like there's supposed to be some
Deadpool Xmen apocalypse captain america
civil war not expecting any doctors
range but just stay tuned and there will
be more Star Wars this week non lego
star wars I want to do a captain phasma
video I need to do a rogue one video
it's a little harder to do rogue one
videos because we haven't really seen
any footage from it yet but be sure to
subscribe to get everything if there is
any kind of special Star Wars stuff that
you guys want this week just let me know
in the comments speaking of Captain
America Civil War if you guys haven't
seen it i just did a Scarlet Witch
vision video you can click here to watch
that and you can click here for my X
Files video from last night thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight me me me
me me